[Music]
he continues to say he hopes we find our
way back to each other sometime down the
road after we've both had time to heal
he began dating other women a week after
we broke up and his statements of Hope
are confusing and I'm unsure how to
grieve let go of Hope and move
[Music]
forward what up what up what up what up
this is John with the Dr John baloney
show show about your mental health your
emotional health your relationships
whatever you got going on in your life
we don't stage any of this these are
real calls from real people
and often they don't know where to turn
or they don't have anybody in their life
that they trust or they've reached out
to those folks and they've just been
recited some cute sayings that have been
stitched into pillows or hanging in
their grandmother's
bathrooms and they want someone to tell
them the truth so that's what this
show's about it's about sitting with
hurting people and we will figure out
what to do next been doing this for
about two decades now sitting with
people when the wheels have fallen
off it's a crazy world out there and I'm
so grateful that you've joined us if you
want to be a part of this show want to
call in we can change your name we can
change your location um we can anonymize
it the best we can I don't even know if
anonymize is a real word is it um I
don't think so but let's rock and roll
with it though might I'm going with it
if you want to be anonymized whatever we
got to do to protect the innocent that
sounds like something we shouldn't do
without some sort of lenser anonymize
people anonymized people it feels like
what those kids in Silicone Valley are
doing trying to anonymize this all
anonym call 1844 693 3291 and leave a
message and we'll holl back girl at you
I ain't no holl girl Kelly is or go to
john.com
askk SK what is a hollow back girl what
does that even mean honestly I'm not
real sure Jenna do you know uh my best
guess is like if a guy is like cat
calling you or something and like you're
not going to holl back at
him huh I don't know that's just what I
get from the song right if you know what
actual like I ain't no Hollow back girl
if you know what that means go to
Kelly's Instagram
account at Kelly Fletcher and tell her
what it means you are you googling it
Kelly
that's going to look good on the work on
the work uh search
engine um let's see here can't wait till
HR this Urban Dictionary so I gota be
real careful with this one Miss Kelly um
did you she this says a hollack girl is
a girl who only responds with verbal
insults but
never never takes it to the next level
she's just mouthy with the insults oh so
she doesn't like actually getting fights
yeah um Andrew had a different
explanation of what a hollat girl
was
figures I mean it's it's what I was told
when I was younger so that's what I was
told I had very bad friends let's go out
to Veronica in Sacramento before we get
cancelled what's up Veronica hi Dr John
thank you for taking my call thank you
for calling what's up so my partner and
I split about six weeks ago because
heor he said he had been unhappy for
some time and had some work to do on
himself he continues to say he hopes we
find our way back to each other sometime
down the road after we've both had time
to heal work on ourselves and hopefully
come back together no with a new way of
doing things he began dating other women
a week after we broke up right um we
share a
two-year-old and I have committed to
remaining excuse
me I've committed to remaining in his
other kid's life he has a seven and an
11y old okay we still do family
activities and seeing him semi semi
regularly excuse me and his statements
of Hope are confusing and I'm unsure how
to grieve let go of Hope and move
forward and just for additional context
when when we first started dating he had
been married for 14 years and his wife
had had an affair and left and I I had
known both him and his wife for quite a
while before then and he had reached out
and at the time I told him you know I
think you need to spend a year figuring
out who you are outside your marriage
reach out to me if I'm still single in a
year great and when he continued to
pursue me I told myself a story that it
was meant to be he was choosing and
picking
me and we got pregnant almost
immediately which was not planned and
that put a lot of pressure on the
relationship and he has explained in the
breakup that he is a police officer off
he did two tours in Afghanistan he came
back and got married and then we
immediately got pregnant and so he does
not feel like he has had the last 20
years he's been in some type of intense
situation and he has not had time to
figure out who he is or what he wants
and so for me I can understand on some
levels that he needs to figure out who
he is but he lost that privilege when he
had a baby with
you
period the figuring out days the
backpacking through Italy days the going
out on a bunch of different dates with a
bunch of different people just to get to
know folks and figure out what you like
and don't like those days are over he's
created two different family units with
two different women and three
kids those are all choices that he
made the hardest thing for you to hear
right now is just the truth and I'm
gonna be honest with you is that cool I
I absolutely hope you'll be with me all
right this relationship's over
period there might be a time in the
future that y'all rebuild something new
but what you had is over complete stop
sign it's done over over the land has
been sold to somebody
else here's where that's really hard for
you yes because you have to you have a
child now
right you also I have a child and he his
kids I've been in therapy um and his two
kids are seven and 11 years old they in
his previous marriage they couldn't have
children so they adopted them and I feel
like the adoption was one form of
Abandonment the divorce was another and
I just Veronica but but here's the thing
you can commit all you want you're not
invited into their life I I am actually
he's he's of course yeah because you're
a babysitter while he's out hooking up
with other
people you're amazing free babysitter
that's not being in their life that's
being taken advantage of yeah and you
can't use them and they're and you can't
use them to make yourself feel better
about this disaster that's upon you yeah
he left he left you with a baby he left
you with a bunch of
promises so you have these two things
you're grieving one is the actual loss
of the relationship he's probably a
pretty fun guy to be around right when
he's fully plugged in right and you'll
have a baby together is it a boy or girl
boy so do you see his daddy and him
every second of every day yes yeah
that's both amazing and hell in this
situation the second thing that you have
to grieve that's that's different than
that is you lost trust in Veronica
because you
knew yeah and now you don't know which
way to what like every step you you take
is like trying to walk on a on a
lake because you don't trust you don't
trust you right
yeah and how old are you I'm 40 have you
been married before when I was 23
okay oh dude so you went all back in on
this one huh I I was I have never been
as all the way in with someone as I have
with him oh
man I'm so sorry
sorry I bet you don't feel like you have
any guts right now do you none
none and I just you know you know I've
listened to your show for a long time
and I appreciate when you share that
like I want to be a mature adult and be
able to be around him and and co-parent
peacefully and we we get along fine you
know we went took the whole family to an
air show this past weekend and then but
it
while I loved us all being together it
was also super painful for me and I just
yeah it's pretend it's pretend you're
playing family yes and he's playing
family and then he got home and he
texted the other girl when he got home
right right
right I hate that for you I'm so
sorry I just I don't know how to let go
of Hope and just move forward I
know I
know
does he want to be in this little baby's
life or is he just dragging on the whole
thing he's a great dad okay he's a great
dad and that's so I think part of it you
know because I love him and I love
seeing him with my son and I always
wanted to be a mom and I didn't get to
be until I was 37 I know you are a mom
and it feels right but now half of his
life I don't get to see anymore you know
and I don't get
to see the joy that comes from watching
the two of them interact
yeah I'm sorry dude that picture you had
was you all painted it together and it
was going to be
forever
yeah I'm so
sorry the
um I think the important thing moving
forward is I think he's told you enough
stories and here's going to sound
something crazy think in his heart and
head there's a chance your husband is
not all evil I think there's actually a
chance that he is trying to unravel this
thing on his
own at all at the same time he's trying
to probably honor his first wife and
those two kids however messy that is and
he's trying to honor you and this new
baby however messy that is and he still
has this other part of him that feels
like was stolen from him while he was
deployed and he wants that too it's it's
a hard I I get it
I don't agree with it and if he was
sitting down with me id say bro but I
get it I understand
it what that means
is you have to take back agency over
Veronica's
life and that starts with you telling
him I refuse to be the other
woman I'm just not unless you're okay
with
that I'm not you're not I mean you're
not you know I'm still close to this
whole family you know they love me and
like I'm a good mom I know you are hold
on hold on whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa
whoa don't you dare hang up this phone
thinking that he left you because of
you because you weren't a good
mom he was pretty clear I left because
of me right because of him yeah yeah
well yes and he
I mean he did say he felt like I had
things to work on I think we we all do
have things that we're trying to work on
Grief yeah you find me two people who
get married who don't have things to
work on good grief that's not even a
real
statement it's not even real of course
be kind and loving and have integrity
and that guy must have been an honor
student well you've got things to work
on too well no kidding genius but here's
the deal from this point forward you
have to draw boundaries around you and
your well-being and the wellbeing of
your child
that means as awful as this sounds
you're going to have to go sit with an
attorney and create actual parenting
guidelines and
boundaries and I know that's not fun I
know that
sucks no and especially because we've
tried to write out our own custody
agreement be very flexible it's not
gonna
work it's going to work until he starts
dating somebody else and gets engaged
again and she wants her life to look a
different
way and then he's going to be obligated
to honor his new wife it's the right
thing to do and it's going to get
messy and so what you're doing is saying
hey you chose to
leave I love you I honor your choice now
I have to protect me and I have to
protect this baby and we're going to put
some of these things in writing I love
you I'm always going to be with you
you're just giving up on us no no no no
no you left you left
period you see the difference I do okay
I do and if 5050 custody doesn't work
out on a regular basis when it comes to
travel and picking up from school and
work schedules then it doesn't work and
you can tell
them I think the best schedule is going
to be X Y and Z I don't want to go to
court I don't want to fight
you you are a great dad to this little
boy but you get to create the world and
put it in front of him and see if he
signs it
right but I think you have to bring
another person in on this deal you also
have to make sure you're covered
financially I I mean I'm very fortunate
that you know I've followed Dave Ramsey
I have no debt I have a really good job
right now a career right
now I would not have a job if
everybody's good job lasted forever ever
I would be unemployed if everybody's
great great awesome moments lasted
forever they don't layoffs happen people
get fired and that kid's still going to
need to eat no and you've been
independent for a long time you're tough
aren't you yeah and you'll be damned if
you're gonna ask some man to get put
money in your account right yes you have
to it's for this little boy and you're
playing a long-term game to this little
boy's 18 if you don't want to take
alimony that's fine but there has to be
some
participation in the day-to-day um
expenses of raising a
kid no right yes now is not a time for
your ego now is a time to take care of
this little boy in the shortterm and in
the long
term yeah the chances that you still
have this great job and this great
opportunity and the great state of
California when he's 18 is slim to
none
well I mean I'm gonna push back on that
a little bit just because of my training
and my profession I can I'm I'm a nurse
so so pry decent job
security unless in three years the
diagnostic system with AI begins to let
people do it at from their
house and you've seen that technology
coming out just like I have right right
yes everyone's got a great job till they
don't those dudes who used to create the
pooper scoopers for the horses were
sitting pretty until Henry Ford came
along right right so I and again I think
in 20 years we're still gonna have
nurses don't get me wrong I hope to God
we do for sure well I mean what I feel
like I hear he saying is that I really
need to advocate for myself and make
sure that I'm secure and my son is
secure in
writing in an official state document
yes yeah I I hear you because I have sat
with too many people five years from now
when he's married to somebody else and
she's
pregnant and she says you will not have
those kids in this house period this is
new
lifetime yeah and suddenly great dad
disappears just like a
ghost and how he pitched in for
groceries and you always just had money
because he was a cool guy now suddenly
that's her money too and I ain't sending
nothing to ex nobody
and that's just I I mean it's just
happened my whole career right
right maybe he's not man this dude's
amazing he just got in over his head and
you y'all were friends and then he
really liked you and he hooked up and
he's like whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa this
is happening again too fast and then
suddenly you had a baby and you know I
maybe that's what how how that happened
I don't want to knock the guy
but um I do think it's wise for both of
you to have this thing secured and you
to advocate for yourself both now and 18
years from
now I hate it for you so a quick thing I
think is helpful when you're grieving it
helps clarify things you've heard me say
this a bunch on this show but I want you
to do this want you to write him three
letters that you will never never going
to send him letter number one is anger
heartbreak sadness I can't believe you
left us
I'm so heartbroken that you left
us you made promises to me you swore to
me and you're gone letter number two is
I'm so grateful you came into my life
and this is usually the Hard One to
write because because of your time
together with him you got this amazing
amazing little
boy he is a good
dad so
here's
you let me believe again whatever you
want to write but the second letter is
how much um that you're glad he came
into your life the third letter is
dear dear
ex I want you to know what you're going
to miss I'm going to be an amazing
mother to our
kid I'm going to make sure and I want
you go on the list he's going to have a
healthy
breakfast that when he starts dating
that I'm not that crazy mom who wants to
fight his girlfriends but I'm gonna be
we're going to talk about sex and we're
going to talk about life and we're going
to talk about philosophy and politics
I'm going to be there for our son you're
going to miss it all CU you left you'll
get the games and you'll get the fun but
you're going to miss watching an amazing
mom love her
son and as you write those things you're
going to begin to feel things things are
going to come up I want you to write
those things that come up and I want you
take time to weep like you haven't wept
yet you take time to be heartbroken
broen and be scared and be like I knew
it Veronica you shouldn't have done it
again and yes you should
have this is all part of the healing
Journey the final thing is is you have
to find two or three women that you
trust and sit down and tell them
everything all of how much you're
hurting you've heard me say this a
million times I'll say it a million more
as David Kessler says grief Demands a
witness you have to sit in front of
somebody and say this happened to me
this happened to somebody I
love I was single and strong for so long
and nobody messed with me and then I
fell head over heels and with a guy I
knew I shouldn't have and they made me a
bunch of promises and we have this
beautiful baby boy and then he left
me and I'd take him back if he said all
that all of it all of it all of it got
to say it out loud in front of other
real people in real
time and that's the beginning of the
grieving
process over and over and over again I'm
super grateful for you Veronica I'm so
sorry this happened
what y'all had is over now he could
Circle back and be like I was wrong I
screwed up whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa
I'm all in I'm all in I'm all in okay
fine y'all got to build something
completely new and he's got a lot of
trust rebuilding to
do what you had is over the only place
you can go is forward now and in the
interim you got to take care of you and
you got to take care of this little boy
I'm grateful for you holler anytime if I
can be of help we'll be right
back hey good folks deloney here with
some great news you get to choose
whatever you do good or bad moving
forward the choice is yours and when
you're intentional about making good
choices over time those become healthy
habits they almost become automatic like
choosing to slow down and make time for
a daily practice of prayer and
meditation one thing that has help me
with my daily practice is hallow hallow
is the number one Prayer app in the
world and they're giving you three free
months to get started that's three
months for free to prioritize your
mental and spiritual health and be
intentional about finding peace through
calming music through guided prayers
meditation and more and by the way
hallow isn't just Catholic you can
tailor the content towards your faith
tradition or if you don't have a faith
tradition it's a great place to start
from scripture readings to prayers to
journaling Hall makes it easy to
practice mindfulness build a deeper more
meaningful spiritual life and choose
peace remember Hall is giving you 90
days free imagine the peaceful habits
you can establish in 90 days go to
hall.com dealone today to start your
free trial just follow the simple
prompts at hall.com
dealone for 90 days
free all right let's go out to Naples
and talk to Iris what's up
Iris hello Dr John thank you for taking
my call of course thanks for calling
what's up oh my God I'm so
excited bring it no nothing much um just
trying to figure out how to do this mom
life in this crazy world I'm not a mom
so I'll just be guessing but go for it
but I'm sure you have some good
insights so uh sorry for my accent H hey
hold on never ever apologize for your
accent ever it's beautiful
oh no anyways hold on no no never
apologize for your the way you talk it's
beautiful it adds color to the
world you
promise absolutely not but
okay battling for 15 years and still
there but anyways thank you for your
words I appreciate be it's beautiful
it's beautiful all right go for so how
do I help my 12 year old boy make
relationship you know relationships with
others friends he's got no friends uh
but I feel it's kind of my fault because
I've been always telling him that like
um people are evil and don't trust
people and stay away from me kids and
why I don't know why'd you tell him that
because it's the truth though
no for a 12y old well he got bullied a
while back and and I'm trying to like
help him not to fail fall for it like I
feel like if kids find him friendship or
friend friendly they're GNA just take
more advantage of him I don't know so
here's an example of of what you did
okay and you know the you listen to the
show before yes you know I love you and
I'm gonna be real honest with you both
at the same time cool bring it okay what
you did was you went into the gym and
you saw your your 12-year old boys
probably 10 11 at the time lifting
weights and you saw that they were heavy
and he was
struggling so instead of getting behind
the bar and helping spot him and putting
a couple of fingers underneath the bar
and helping him lift you took all the
weight off the bar and then you hung the
bar up and you said never lift
again because that's too
heavy and so he got bullied and then Mom
said hey you can't ever handle this
you're always going to be subjected to
people taking advantage of you your best
option for life is to
hide you see what I'm saying SP on
exactly how I feel okay you have to
throw that nonsense into reverse on the
highway like
today okay because his body is going to
respond to Mom he's going to absorb the
tension of the adults in his
life and he's going to learn others
aren't safe and the problem is our
bodies use other people like oxygen you
cannot do life without them I know and
that's where I find myself at the you
know the fork of like he needs to make
friendships and relationships and then
now he's not you need friendships and
relationships first oh
true you you Iris all right how do you
know these things here's the path
forward it's a simple path and it's
going to be the worst you ready mhm you
have to take him out out to dinner is
his dad in the picture yes yes what does
Dad think about all
this he think I'm
crazy for
what for even I don't know for
even ah I don't know he's we're very
different tell me
how I mean I don't he's he's a man so he
I am
too I have a 13-year-old little boy I
want him to have a bunch of friends a
whole bunch of I could do different
friends that tell them all kind of crazy
things and they get into hyinks together
yeah and he does my husband he's he's
got friends he plays Bas with them and
okay H but I I don't see myself doing
those kind of
things okay you for the sake of your son
you are now I gotta yeah so the path
forward is you
Mom you take him out to a special meal
just the two of you
and let him
know I've got to talk to you about
something serious and
special and he'll go oh geez here we go
again mom and I want you to say magic
words what he says I know because you've
been doing it his whole life you've been
lecturing him telling them that things
are scary and people are awful and
things are terrible and and and and and
don't talk like that and be weary of
your accent people are going to make fun
of you and they're look right you've
been telling that his whole
life 100% And I feel all full body okay
cool and now it's time to change you
cannot change one second of what
happened from right now in into the past
but you can change everything about what
comes
next I want you to take him out I want
you to look him across the table I want
you to hold both of his hands and he's
going to be all weird about it like Mom
and say no hold my hands and I want you
to say these magic words I was
wrong I was
wrong I was scared for somebody to hurt
my little boy
again and out of my own fear I cast it
on
you and I taught you to be afraid of the
world are you going to get hurt in the
world yes but is the path forward to
hide from the world no it's to become
strong and confident in the face of
what's
coming and those are two different
things okay that's number one and he's
going to say okay thanks Mom fine fine
fine
and I want you to make a commitment to
yourself for the next I don't know 90
days three months you want to get weird
let's get weird you Iris have to invite
adult friends to your house once a week
for the next 90 days oh your son has to
see you have friends yep and you can't
be all awkward about
it and I know you're going to be cuz I
I'm super
awkward yeah I read your book about it
and I've been trying to and it's like
how do I even say all the people to
let's move friend let's move him off the
side why do you think you're not worth
having friends I don't know no I don't
even think he's that is like I find hard
time connecting why with others like I'm
I maybe have a standard and I need to
bring it down much no that's not it from
thinking what do you what do you mean
what's your standard
I don't know I rather I'm I'm I want to
do religion but I'm Christian and i'
rather you just be surrounded by people
that think around the same
and kind of like that but it's not even
that I don't know I get that I'm
Christian too and some of my best
friends on planet Earth don't believe in
anything and that's okay maybe that's
what I'm struggling with of course it's
okay they're still great moms and dads
okay there they're amazing parents we
just we just disagree and I love that
and I especially here's what I
especially love I love my son and my
daughter around people who do Church
different than us who do no church at
all who think differently than us I love
them around those great people while
they're in my home because while they're
in my home they're going to ask
me when they leave my home they're going
to run into these people all over the
place and two things happen number one
they go to Google instead of me
and so I'm turning over virtue I'm
turning over development I'm turning
over value creation to the
internet when I had 18 years of my own
home that's number one number two your
kids are going to run into people who
love differently than they do look
differently than they do speak different
languages than they do do religion
differently than they do and they're
going to find they're amazing people and
they're fun and they have great values
and they're great parents and then
they're going to going to think my mom
was lying to me the whole time I wonder
what else she was lying to me about yeah
right yeah and so trying to create a
bubble and that's right not working out
it never works
out now when you're a four or fiveyear
old fine bubbles are good but when your
kid gets to be
12 yeah he's got to have a bunch of
knuckleheaded buddies he's running
around doing stuff
with right yep and how old are you right
now 34 you need that
too you need that
too and here's the thing if you think
hold on if you think because of your
particular
religion that you are above people you
need to reimagine your religion no no
it's not that I I know but you said I
need to lower my
standard and so you do my my my own like
I don't even know what I meant I don't
know yeah but it's true so here's your
homework you've got to go make friends
your and you have to do it where your
kid can see it or hey you're on your own
for dinner tonight honey because I'm
going to hang out with my girlfriends
we're going to have fun what you
yes husband son y'all are on your own
and by the way son go with Dad and watch
him play baseball not to watch him play
baseball does he do that do they go okay
yeah they take he takes him everywhere
good that's the beauty of them too they
they have a beautiful relationship
awesome well he's getting to watch his
dad have friends which is good
yeah that's fantastic and then here's
the other thing you have to start
inviting other 12y olds 11y olds
13-year-olds into your
house
okay and let it roll yeah obviously keep
him safe obviously don't have him around
violent or evil
Knuckleheads it's not like I'm on on TV
kind of freak clean freak so I'll I'll
work on it you're a clean freak or he is
oh I am so that's probably why we don't
do anything the house and everything
okay there was one uh there was one
group recently that uh a couple that
similarly So at their homework
assignment it's actually a a show that
we filmed that's going to be coming out
in a few weeks I one of their homework
assignments was they had to have a
different couple over every week and
they had to mess up one thing in their
living room leave a basket of laundry
out leave plates with food on them in
the
sink because for some reason you've told
your you've taught yourself or somebody
taught you and you believe it that your
only value
is being clean that's right yep and let
me tell you something I can tell you by
just this phone call you're probably
pretty hilarious aren't
you I can be yes I bet you're really
funny and I bet you're super hilariously
opinionated about things right yep how
do you know these things without even
metting me before I can hear it I can
hear how you're communicating with me I
would like to hang out with you are you
an amazing cook yep y I think so I would
love to sit at your table and eat and
just completely get into arguments about
politics with you I would love that
because I bet you're hilarious about it
and I bet you get so mad and then 13
seconds later we're friends again yep
yes why would you rob your neighbors of
how awesome you
are
I don't
know can I ask you a hard hard question
that's kind of mean go for
it when your husband and son are gone
and the dishes are all clean and
everything's
spotless do you have that feeling of
loneliness
inside every time every
time you're worth having friends and for
God's sakes don't give that pit in your
stomach to your son too I know and
that's why I'm calling that's why I I
knew you had an answer yeah here's the
thing I I'm saying this because I love
you he is very very vulnerable right now
here's why yeah he's gonna
crave desperately like a drug
friendships and other
people and because he thinks there's
something wrong with
him so much so that he was so weak that
it had to be withdrawn from Human
contact
because his mom didn't come in and say
oh you can't lift this we're putting
more weight on the bar and we're going
to do this every day until you get
strong he's going to gravitate towards
kids that will pray on him even
more and that's my fear right so it
created the thing the very thing you
were the most scared of yeah right and
so he might need to go to counseling for
a bit and learn some skills on how to
deal with bullies okay he might need a
mom that's like you can do anything and
who lets him try so that he's got able
to stand up and when that bully says
that's a stupid shirt you he can go man
you got the best shirt and on in school
and the bully doesn't know what he's uh
what what what right you can teach him
some of those skills or better yet his
friends can he can continue to go play
with his dad but at the end of the day
he's going to look with a side eye at
his
mom and he's going to see her having
friends and and he's going to see her
not carrying if there's an extra dish in
the sink because she's got a group of
women over and they're being loud and
silly and
arguing and he's going to have a couple
of knuckleheaded 12-year-olds running
around in the backyard and and and why
because y'all are worth relationships
you're worth friendships you're worth
all of
it and we're not going to hang our head
in shame could we have done this
differently yes and are you a pretty
amazing mom cuz you caught yourself and
you want to do something different Absol
freaking abolutely I love you for it
Iris I'm so proud of
you but let's have that lunch that
breakfast that dinner today tomorrow I'm
sorry I cast my loneliness onto you and
I was wrong those kids that were ugly to
you when you were six and seven and
eight and nine we're we're done
running because you're my son and you
should throw your head back shoulders
back head held high cuz you're my
son hang on the line I'm going to send
you all the questions for humans for the
for uh kids parents friends teens I'm
going to send them all of them and that
would be a good Gateway for you and him
to start talking and I'm going to send
you the grown-up ones too I'm G to send
you all the decks all of them I think we
got like 20 of them man I'm going to
send the whole truckload and you can use
them with your friends when you're
sitting there feeling your heart starts
to beat fast like oh my is my house
clean enough I don't know you're going
to have some conversation starters and
by the way I used them this morning with
my 13-year-old at our breakfast this
morning and he was kind of annoy annoyed
by him he's like D I want to sit here
nope we're doing it we're talking then
we got into some good
conversations I'm going to send them all
to you to take away that like I don't
know what to do next I got you I got you
questions for
humans I'm proud of you for making a
change but you got to go make the change
you're worth it so is
he you're awesome we'll be right
back this episode is sponsored by better
help hey folks delone here sometimes we
know what's good for us but it feels
like we just can't make ourselves do it
like our brain's getting in its own way
and that happens to me a lot and I'm
pretty sure it happens to you I know I
should play a game with my kids instead
of practicing my guitar all night but
sometimes my brain tells me that hey
maybe that metal band's going to call
after all you got to get your practice
in therapy helps me figure out what's
holding me back from doing what I know I
should do and it can help you too so
your brain can begin to work with you
not against you
sometimes it's just as simple as talking
things through and learning how to
intentionally Place guard rails between
yourself and negative behaviors we call
them boundaries so if you're thinking of
starting therapy give betterhelp a try
better help is flexible because it's
totally online so it can fit your
schedule just fill out a brief
questionnaire to get matched with the
licensed therapist you can switch
therapist at any time for no extra
charge make your brain your friend with
better help visit betterhelp.com delone
to today to get 10% off your first month
that's betterhelp
hp.com
delone all right let's go out to Tampa
Florida and talk to the great Steve
what's up
Steve hey Dr John how are you we're good
man what's happening in your world oh
not much just trying to keep it together
aren't we all man aren't we all what's
up brother how can I
help so um I've been um I've been
listening to your show for a long time
and and one of the things you you always
tell people to do when they're when
they're struggling in their
relationships and their marriage is Turn
All the Lights On have a conversation
about um what's going on and and try to
find a way moving forward and for for me
and um me and my wife she's been
struggling with depression and anxiety
for most of our marriage and I've had
those conversations multiple times I've
tried to go to counseling with her I've
gone to counseling
myself and she just keeps getting darker
and it just keeps getting worse and I
don't know how to love and support her
when things just aren't getting
better what does she
say thank you for your heart by the way
man
um it's a pretty amazing heart you have
dude thank you what does she say
when you turn the lights on and you say
Hey what how can I love you what does
she
say sometimes she'll say yeah we we we
need to move forward we need to look at
counseling we need to look at changing
some things and then it doesn't happen
other times she
says I'm just not good enough um you'd
be better off without me that's was that
was the language I was I was wondering
about it sounds like she's
done and you said something important I
tell people to turn the lights on and
stop the
music not so we can all move forward
together that comes next that's step two
step one
is look at the mess we've created look
at the dance we're doing together do we
want to keep doing
this and if you both agree oh my gosh we
did not mean for the party to get this
out of control
yes we got to make some changes then we
start talking about how do we move
forward
together
okay so when I say it sounds like she's
done does that ring true to you or do I
sound crazy and I I'm not in I don't
have a vested interest in being right
I'm really asking
you yes and no there there are times
when she's in the the Dark Places it
seems like she's just done she wants to
walk away and she doesn't doesn't want
to be involved with us or the kids me
and the kids anymore and then after a
period of her just kind of being by
herself for a while then she turns
around and everything's fine and when I
try to have conversations in those time
it's like that past conversation never
happened she doesn't even recognize that
it
happened so in those good days
it's it's fine and is she bipolar has
she been diagnosed with bipolar disorder
she has not she has not she's not been
diagnosed with anything um but it seems
like depression and anxiety maybe even
bipolar I think it would be important
for her to go get a true psychological
evaluation and I I know I'm I am
frustrated by the diagnostic system but
sometimes it's very very
important
yeah because my my initial question is
what is her body trying to tell her by
being anxious and depressed all the
time and what I'm hearing is you got two
healthy kids is that right three healthy
kids
yeah you're probably not a perfect
husband but be honest with me are you a
pretty good husband you try pretty hard
I try Okay sometimes I succeed are
you I was goingon to say sounds like a
all do you scream and yell in the house
do you punch holes in the
sheetrock uh I haven't punched the hole
in the sheetrock for about 10 years but
I do scream on occasion okay we're done
with that today
right do I have your word you're done
with
that yes screaming in a house is what
children do we're done with that okay do
you cheat on her absolutely not do you
go to
work I no I work from home I do you have
a job that's what I'm getting at yes yes
okay so you
provide
okay I wonder if something bigger is at
play it seems like it okay it seems
like it's there's just something she's
struggling with and I can't I don't know
how to help okay here's the thing you
can't unless she invitees you in m and
if it becomes Sinister or dark or she's
hurting herself or she's hurting you or
she's hurting the children you have to
take action to keep people safe which is
different than trying to quote unquote
fix your marriage
mhm has she ever um been
suicidal she has mentioned it on
occasion
okay what does that mean mentioned it
like I I wish I just wasn't here
or last night I almost took my
life more like mentioned if I if I just
wasn't here
okay would she be open to going to meet
with a psychologist and get an
evaluation
I've talked about it a a time or two and
when we have the conversations uh she
says she will but then she doesn't want
to follow through on it okay it might be
important for you to make an
appointment
okay and she's gonna have to fill out
paperwork for that appointment but I
think it's important for you to sit down
and say I'm now
scared I'm scared I'm going to lose you
I'm going to lose this home I'm going to
lose my
family and I'm not going down without a
fight
and even if you have to offer as well
I'm going to go get a psychological
evaluation for
me I want to be better at this I want
you to come and get one
too You' said you would in the past I've
made us an
appointment and I've taken off of work I
will
drive okay yeah if you have somebody
that you love and they are in a very
dark place um depression is so so real I
don't talk about depression a lot
because it manifests differently than
anxiety does even though they're on the
same trend line when people talk about
depression they often use words like
pain because the parts in the brain that
that process emotional pain also process
physical pain it is a disaster
true um depressive disorders okay yes
and so it's easy if you don't have
depression to look and say just make the
call
yeah and they look at you with that look
in their eye and they say my body won't
make the call right yeah I know that
look and yeah you know that so similar
if you saw her drowning you would jump
in and pull her out of the water then
and sometimes I'm gonna make the phone
call okay yeah so I think and often
people don't want to go alone they don't
want to be the weird isolated one cool
I'll get a work up too that's fine and
it's GNA be very expensive and it's
gonna be worth every penny of it for our
family
yeah
okay yeah
that's that's something I can do okay
but yeah when you sit down with her the
conversation has to be about Steve and
Steve's fear and worry and concern for
the family and her your concern over her
health and her peace
okay
okay that might be where I've struggled
in the past it's been more about what
I've seen in her not right necessarily
how I am and my guess is people have
been telling her her whole life what she
should be doing differently or
better and when she gets it from the guy
that she loves her defense mechanisms
just take
over that makes sense and some people's
defense mechanisms send them to war and
they scream and fight and punch and kick
back and some people's defense
mechanisms just show the whole thing
down yeah she come from a pretty a
pretty tough upbringing yes yeah yeah
her parents were difficult yeah her body
may have put a GPS pin in mom and dad
and that GPS pin is sounding every alarm
every time you enter into that
space yeah that makes sense maybe a lot
maybe you start the conversation a
little bit differently say I've been
trying to fix you for a long time and I
don't think you're broken I think you're
my lovely beautiful wife
and I'm sorry for not trusting you in
your
body she might look at you like what did
you do with my husband where is he
where's
Steve
um I think yeah if you make it about you
I'm scared because I love you so much I
can't I can't even breathe and I I am
scared for how you feel I'm scared for a
kids I'm scared for me I'm scared for my
marriage yeah and I'll go to hell back
to come get
you will you go to the doctor with me
okay
yes you think she would she respond to
that that feels
safer it feels safer she she might
respond to that that's at least
something different you know okay and
maybe you want to do something gangster
write her a letter and read it to
her yeah and then let her let her have
it cuz sometimes a brain that's
struggling with depression it it has to
go through a
warbly processing center that can take
even the most lovely sentiments the most
lovely kind things and twist them around
like oh you said that because you hate
me right yeah and so when you write a
letter to somebody who's struggling with
depression and you read it to them their
body feels that safety even when their
mind is telling them it's not safe and
then you leave that letter and it gives
them chance to go back and go back and
go
back something tangible that's yeah and
over time that's actually not what he
said he said he'll be here forever
because he loves me so much he didn't
say I was crazy he didn't say he was
going to leave me he said he was scared
because he loves me so
much that's a good idea okay and also if
you're like me you I get these big
grandiose moments I'm going to have this
big conversation and then I get all
nervous and I screw it up up right so
writing it down sometimes gives me some
clarity a path
forward but my friend Steve I'm so proud
of you dude for loving your
wife and I'm proud of you for looking in
the toolkit you got and say okay I've
been trying to hang drywall with this
hammer and a ruler I need different
tools because this isn't cutting it and
I appreciate that give this a shot and
don't hesitate to call me back man um
and by the way you might make this big
presentation read this thing to her tell
her you love her tell her you're scared
for you and that you are scared for her
health and you want to know how you can
love her better you've made the
appointments with a psychologist to get
a work up if you can't afford both of
them that's fine she you can call and
get her set up and she might say I'm not
ready to
go I love
you I want to get together once a week
just a quiet private date with us and
I'm going to send you the both questions
for humans decks cards as well I'm going
to send them to you the couple's cards
and I want you all just to use them you
don't have to talk about anything that's
going wrong in the house all you're
doing is slowly connecting you're
building a you're building a bridge
underneath a car hanging over and
overpass you're building a second bridge
so that when the big one Falls you got
something to catch you're just building
connection and then you could say hey
have you thought about going to that
appointment still on the books yeah I'll
go I'll drive yeah I'll
go and now we're in business
she lucky to have you brother call me
anytime anytime we'll be right
back hey what's up deloney here listen
you and me and everybody else on the
planet has felt anxious or burned out or
chronically stressed at some point in my
new book building a non- anxious life
you'll learn the six daily choices that
you can make to get rid of your anxious
feelings and be able to better respond
to whatever life throws at you so you
can build a more peaceful nonanxious
life get your copy today at John
del. all right we're back and it's time
for another end of show installment of
I'm the problem it's me all right
today's is from Caitlyn in hold on I'm
the problem is it me right I'm just been
calling it I'm the problem you call it
which you want I'm the problem I just
love Taylor Swift okay uh this is from
Caitlyn in North Carolina my husband
works out of town three to four days at
a time we have a 2 and 1/2-year-old and
a 3-month-old my 2 and 1/2-year-old has
a fever for the fourth night in a row
and wants me to rock him and my 3 Month
needs to go down to sleep thankfully my
husband is home so I asked him to lay
the baby down he was trying to get
insurance for a vehicle we have and had
to stop so he could help me he gets
annoyed and says there's not enough time
in the day this is your job am I crazy
for asking him to help with the kids
when he's home I'm a stay-at-home mom
and I feel like I'm drown I'm drowning
sometimes in situations I'll be it rare
like this one but at the same time we
agreed when we quit my when I quit my
job to be a stay-at home mom that this
would be my job I hate feeling like this
am I the
problem no you're not the problem good
God a wow okay imagine this guys who are
at work imagine you are a vice president
and you're in a suit and you're walking
down the hallway and there is somebody
who's a part of the custodial team and
they're cleaning up and they're empty
one trash can into a bigger trash sack
and they drop a plastic cup on the
ground would you look at them and say
you picked that up that's your job no
you wouldn't do that you would go oh
gosh I got it I got it I got it and
you'd reach down and you put that
plastic cup and you pick it up and you
drop it in
there yet to our wives
who leave their professional jobs to
stay at
home we have in our mind that's her job
and this is my
job that's not how home life works you
can set up job descriptions hey you're
going to manage the house while I go
make money and you make sure this and
I'll make sure this that sounds all good
and then life happens and then you're
empty in the trash and some of it falls
and human beings stop and help each
other pick up trash I don't care what
your job title is I don't care how much
money you make
similarly man I really want to get this
thing done that could by the way have
been done in hotel rooms and in airports
across the country but you wait till you
got home that's fine and your wife says
hey I need some
help this could be your moment man where
you're like yes finally I can help right
here's the deal most dads most of the
time feel like they don't have any value
with their presence I'm just going to go
drop a 3-month-old into a bassinet that
that's my job today I need a bigger job
than that one that I do well like
shopping
Insurance go be awkward and go be weird
and go pick up the baby no the problem
is not you moms ask for help ask for
help husbands step up new dads step
up everybody has the same job
description when it comes to raising
kids it's all in all the time love you
guys bye
[Music]